Je pense que beaucoup de gens supposent
dans le public
que
toutes les personnes touchées
ont été aidées par le gouvernement, mais
les survivants civils viennent d'être
laissés pour compte et c'est une tragédie
à certains égards. Je me sens engourdi
et
je fais toutes ces choses que je  devrait
être en train de faire et donc le ptsd ne disparaît pas mais
il diminue en intensité
je n'ai pas
reçu de diagnostic
avant
2017. et
cela m'a traversé le fait d'avoir un
conducteur dui conduisant sous l'influence
mais le programme ici dans le comté de forsyth en
géorgie c'était à travers ça  programme que j'ai reçu
le diagnostic
les soins de santé dans notre système notre système
aux états-unis est censé être l'
un des meilleurs
pourtant
nous avons eu cette horrible tragédie sur le
sol américain et maintenant nous avons des élus
prétendant que c'est fini que tout le monde
s'en occupe  de
[Musique]
ce sont les mêmes politiciens qui ont dit
ne jamais oublier ne jamais oublier de se
promener avec leurs petits drapeaux
c'est pourquoi je ne vais pas à new york
pour cet anniversaire j'ai été à quatre
cinq fois je '  J'ai parlé à l'ouverture
du musée
mais l'hypocrisie exposée
est dégoûtante alors je reste à l'intérieur des terres